so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the perfect way to start the show
i'm elios and this is future play direct
summer's here and what better way to
spend it than turning up the heat with
the best the galaxy has to offer
let's get fired up
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
i'm via martino i'll i'll text you
i have a good feeling about this
[Music]
[Applause]
you can't even imagine how busy i am
[Music]
imagine a world on the brink of freedom
from colonial oppression
2262
crime
class conflict
propaganda a familiar story hindered
only by those with plenty of time and
little to lose
detective myegan hill
the sleuth of agonoski
avoiding the past became second nature
dedicating her days to the faceless
rejected citizens of agamotsky until
mary that is
this case goes way farther than the
banks of this one detective's little
neighborhood
[Music]
life is all missing kids and cheating
spouses until a dame from the upper
district barges in and changes your life
[Music]
who will chef rhubarb eliminate this
week text 10 free smells each month with
a one year family plan the government
said it plans to distribute artificial
snow to every household this winter on a
weekly basis
live from hilianthis it's chef rhubarb
hello darling
how much would you love to come on my
show and cook with me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
meet the heroes of soundfall
melody
her sister bright
jackson
kai
and lydia
together they are the guardians of
harmony
melody is a lonely musician with stage
fright who protects symphonia from the
forces of discord with the audioblade
a nimble weapon with a devastating spin
attack
jackson is an irresponsible but charming
metal guitarist who chops down
discordians with the powerful audio axe
and uses his experience as a concert
goer to stage dive to victory
lydia is a famously anti-social cello
superstar who attacks her enemies from
afar with the perfectly precise audio
bow and unleashes volleys of special
arrows to keep away the crowd
bright is a high-energy punk rocker
whose weapon of choice is the sturdy
audio shield which she uses to smash
discordians and create impenetrable
force fields to protect her friends
last but not least is kai a
perfectionist dj who slices and dices
discordians of all sizes with the
unstoppable audio side watch out
discordians that side is a long range
weapon
fight to the beat in soundfall available
now on steam and all major consoles
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
spells and secrets
i'm all fired up and the only way it
could get any better is to hear from the
developers themselves
oh wait
let's do just that
[Music]
i am the co-creator of calico i'm
creative director of unpacking and i'm
the co-creator and art director of
button city
[Music]
if this even remotely looks like your
kind of game it is indeed your kind of
game you know what that is so true
you could tell if it's your vibe just by
looking at the colors this game is a mix
of animal crossing and stardew valley
except you can pick cats up and jiggle
jiggle we should put jiggle jiggle in
the marketing language i love when
things are unexpectedly gay i love that
too i am always surprised when that
happens yes cried my eyes out at the end
10 out of 10. oh i'm so glad we got
people to cry
like that's one of the big check boxes i
cried a few times toward the end like a
little bit not gonna lie i i actually
love watching people watch the credits i
just i love seeing if we manage to move
people so basically it's a game about
stealing cats and putting them in your
cafe sounds right i think it's a really
effective way to collect cats honestly i
found my cat in a bush so i was playing
button city a cute wholesome game and
then on day two the most hardcore metal
music blasts through my ears oh my god
you got the metal yoga we called it claw
core let me put the soy sauce in the
fridge i don't want room temperature soy
sauce oh no
sorry we let you down if you could open
fridges you wouldn't be able to put
magnets on them sorry it was one or the
other no matter how much my horse clips
into the horizon i just can't dislike
this cute game
we keep trying to fix that got a
girlfriend in the game 10 out of 10.
congrats sherlock sherlock is their name
yeah i'm not just calling them sherlock
i'm just like 30 minutes in and i would
die for pedrams that's a common
sentiment i love this game so much that
even though i originally bought it on
the switch i bought it again on steam
just so i could positively review it oh
my god you are a game developer's dream
thank you so much we made this game for
you i am so glad that so many people
seem to be enjoying it that's just
that's our main goal and it's okay if
you cry you can tell us
was this like an actual like thumbs down
not recommended for soy sauce one yeah
oh my god
[Music]
oh
here we go
melly wow you look great is that 4k
hey baby
so what so what's the theme this time
huh are you are you still in space
i mean it looks like you're still in
space i can see your background
do you get tired of being up there i
mean it's not so bad i mean but then
again you get to see all the all the new
games in the galaxy have you had any
cool aliens are they making games too
it's so good to see you but i'm live and
in orbit for a short moment what's up oh
god i i couldn't resist giving you a
ring i got so many new things to tell
you about so tell me everything and give
me an update about what's going on on
your end of the galaxy oh boy okay here
comes here comes the ultra special just
for you sneak peek
i've been so so hard at work at pen pal
princess there's new animations new art
the same cute aesthetic that you are all
familiar with if you name it i
got it in store for you but that's not
all
i'm very very excited to announce our
brand new unreleased character our
knight character look at her
big
beefy
strong orc beats you up sends you love i
see her i see her and oh look at those
muscles i know and she can beat you up
or she can write you a letter and
personally like i'm a fan of both you
know what i'm saying you know you know
what i mean i mean i love a woman who
can kick my ass
classic classic
well we're running out of time baby any
final words you make that sound so
ominous time's ticking baby okay um you
can find us on twitter at pen pal
princess you find me on twitter at bilby
ten seconds uh
uh our kickstarter is coming really
really soon it's getting harder to hear
you um
my name is puppet and i love you
bye phoebe what
babies the biggest ball of energy and i
love that about them
but now that we're alone let's dig into
some dark and dangerous games together
shall we
huh
[Music]
my
my
[Music]
[Music]
la
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
remember this
measure twice
cut once
and tethers
are your friends
they'll sweat
happens to the best of us
the company is your family and we
[Music]
were sent here with a purpose but
[Music]
we're not doing that anymore
[Music]
[Music]
will you join me
everett
[Music]
hmm
i remember this place
but it isn't how i remember it
[Music]
oh i just need more time
[Music]
i know i can remember
i
want to remember
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
do
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
i'm feeling refreshed so many amazing
games are coming this year let's propel
towards the future and get a taste of
what's to come get hyped with me
uh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
what
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i just don't know how to say goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i love you
thanks for tuning in wherever you are if
you liked what you saw check out our
steam event that's going on right now
there you can pick up and wish list some
of the cosmic bangers that you saw
during the show
oh and don't forget to follow along with
us at heyglitch on tiktok and twitter
for fresh posts and chaotic curations
don't want you missing out on the future
dear player huh
oops gotta run i'll be seeing you in the
future until then emilio signing off
[Music]
take
five or whichever take it is take ten
take five okay i'm doing it
oh god you make that sound really up
[Music]
ominous okay okay one more time
new art the same cutest thing that you
are the other one
let me try that again
[Music]
there they go goodbye forever
[Music]
bye